ce
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
et bien la suite des auditions des
sénateurs de la commission des lois à
propos du projet de loi notre nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république en clair la deuxième partie
de la réforme territoriale puisque après
avoir examiné la carte des régions et
après avoir d'ailleurs proposé sa propre
carte des régions le sénat va se pencher
en séance publique à partir du mois de
décembre sur la deuxième partie de cette
réforme parti qui porte sur les
compétences qui vont elles choir aux
différents niveaux de l'organisation du
territoire aussi bien les régions que
les départements l'intercommunalité ou
encore les communes ce matin les
sénateurs ont déjà auditionné les
représentants du département par exemple
avec le président de l'assemblée des
départements de france claudy lebreton
ainsi que les représentants des régions
notamment alain rousset président de
l'association des régions de france cet
après midi là il poursuivre dans la même
veine puisque il auditionne l1 jacques
pélissard président de l'amf
l'association des maires de france ainsi
que jean louis puissegur qui est mon
produit bureau de la m est également
président de l'association des maires de
haute garonne tout de suite on prend
donc la direction la salle clemenceau
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les rapporteurs et messieurs les ses
intérêts chers collègues parlementaires
mais merci de m'accueillir procèdent aux
auditions relatives à la loi notre
nouvelle organisation territoriale la
république évidement je rêvais j'en ai
vu ségur membres du biollay mef donc
disons élément à porter à la
connaissance de la commission des lois
du sénat en terme en guise
d'introduction je vous dis à plusieurs
choses d'abord et c'est une position que
j'exprime nom du bureau de mf n'est pas
ma position personnelle c'est la
position que je ne suis plus vieux et
moi exprimeront au nom de l'ensemble du
bus roulent mf avec sa pluralité avec
son approche collective nous aurions
préféré une loi cadre c'est vrai que la
loi du 25 janvier 2014 de loi matam plus
la loi neutre ça donne une approche
parfois un peu fragmentée aurait préféré
avoir une voix kaki ensuite puisse être
déclinée donc en fonction des
grandes orientations définies on est
passé un peu à côté de ces démarches qui
moi me paraissait plus rationnelle que
celle qui a été en fait suivi moyenne
sur ce deuxième chose nous aurions
souhaité aussi avoir une étude d'impact
financier on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
quel va être l'impact financier de cette
loi notre comme on ne sait pas non plus
quel soit celui de la loire madame du
27 janvier 2014
toute une série d'éléments financiers
sur le coup des métropoles jeunes rats
faisons finale par rapport à l'enveloppé
normée prise sur l'homme dormait sur
l'ensemble des gouttes de l'ag mappy la
gestion de musique aux tic et
l'appréhension à ses visions des
inondations le produit la taxe prévue
donc tout ça c'est très flou et pour la
loi note l'étude d'impact aurait aussi
peut être plus encore donc été
souhaitable et deuxième relation
liminaire termes d'introductions puis
troisième chose et nous aurions souhaité
et ça c'est une vieille demande donc
unanimes du bourg de mf que avec le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit c'est une
de mon ancienne que nous avons et que
nous avons à l'est mais qu il y ait une
instance de dialogue de concertation
puisse en amont du parlement bien calés
toutes ces deux positions par l'écouté
mutuelle la compréhension mutuelle de
nos contraintes respectives état
collectivités territoriales et c'est
dans ce contexte monsieur le président
que j'aime écrire à monsieur président
du sénat gérard larcher pour lui dire
est ce que le sénat pourrait être ne
devrait-il pas être celui de
concertation pour définir les grands
enjeux avec l'association des
départements de france l'association des
régions de france c'est grand et bien
sûr l'association des maires de france
c'est ce grand enjeu décliner
collectivement donc sous l'égide du
sénat pour que l'on puisse bien avoir
une vision d'ensemble de la réforme
territoriale et de la réforme des
rapports avec l'état qui s'avère
parfaitement nécessaire voici ce que je
tenais monsieur le président messieurs
les rapporteurs à dire en introduction
ensuite j'aurai quelques items à vous
développer premier suivante pas donc
recourir à une ce que j'appelais une
décentralisation verticale avec de
nouvelles tutelle on a un peu le
sentiment que la loi notre prévoit de
nouvelles tutelle donc dont seraient
victimes les communes intercommunalités
les schémas prescriptif je dis très
simplement ne sont pas acceptables
qu'ils soient et collaborer oui qu'il ya
les schémas qui permettent d'organiser
l'action publique un vrai intéressante
donc oui au schéma mais avec une
collaboration est pas une décision
unilatérale des régions par exemple sur
par exemple le développement économique
nous sommes partenaires des vrais
comiques un développement économique
nous sommes tous ici aussi des des élus
de terrain et il faut bien sûr une
direction et une fois un schéma donc
evos in un territoire sur lequel se
développent les créations les extensions
d'entreprises si bien tandem région bloc
local communautaire comme il permet
d'avancer de façon intelligente et
harmonieuse donc qu élaborons les
schémas plutôt que de les voir s'imposer
à nous nous ne sommes pas des sous
traitants de quelques niveaux territoire
que ce soit nous sommes un bloc local
qui devait qui devons avoir et nous
devons avoir donc nos responsabilités et
nous devons les assumer donc premier
point et vic est vécue en évitant de
cerises de nouvelles
centralisation ou décentralisation
verticale en provenance des régions ou
des départements
je pense par exemple au département mais
je reviendrai au schéma petite enfance
la très franchement ça ne tient pas
debout le schéma petite enfance élaboré
par le département alors que nous avons
la totalité de cette responsabilité
toutes les crèches tout et
halte-garderie toutes les crèches
familiales tout sont organisées et
financées donc par les collectivités et
les parents et la caisse d'allocations
familiales le département une part très
minoritaire dans ce schéma donc son
intervention paraîtrait un petit peu
anormal
deuxième items que je tenais à dire vous
dire laissons
au bloc local les compétences de
proximité et quelques exemples je viens
donner celui de la petite enfance des
son bloc local assumer cette compétence
petite enfance sur toutes les actions d
ingénierie moi j'ai vu avec intérêt le
discours de monsieur valls devant le
sénat où il dit pratiquement qui il va
laisser aux départements les tâches des
génériques or non ces tâches dégénéré
son étage qui ressort de la compétence
du bloc local de la proximité
voit par exemple ce que nous avons fait
dans beaucoup de communes du territoire
en matière de d'instruction des permis
de construire l'état s'est retiré de
cette instruction mdeur mis en place au
niveau souvent des intercommunalités des
bureaux d'études pour eux donc instruire
les permis de construire la signature
restant la compétence municipale c'est
une bonne démarche cette démarche là
aussi de proximité fait remonter au
niveau départemental ça sera mon sens
moins efficace que la gestion locale
même chose sur l'ingénierie technique
sur la gestion par des syndicats c'est
au niveau d'un bassin de vie d'un bassin
pertinent sur telle technologie que ses
amis cas qui sont les émanations des
communes qui peuvent parfois être
intégrés dans les communautés de
communes ou communautés d'agglomération
quand leurs périmètres coïncide avec
interviews d'auteurs question c'est
comme cela qu'on est efficace si on a
donc une dimension plus large
départemental par exemple on aura mon
sens - efficacité dernier exemple sur ce
te volonté que nous avons de voir le
bloc local conserver des compétences de
proximité c'est un un élément cette fois
ci qui était assez région qui me paraît
très enfants pas faisable c'est la
compétence scolaire pour les transports
scolaires on a donc des grandes régions
quel que soit leur nombre est finalement
retenu mais c'est grande région ne
permettent pas une gestion fine de
proximités transport scolaire et c'est
dans ce domaine là une gestion beaucoup
plus proche qui d'autre est assurée par
des départements préserver dans de
grandes régions ou par les
intercommunalités
le fait de décider en gestion directe en
régie directe ou en en négation c'est
celui que tu étais le bus va passer un
tel ou tel amour donc ramassé tell tale
enfants c'est pas au niveau de la grande
région que ça pourrait être géré voici
donc ce que je tiens à vous dire
monsieur le président messieurs les
amateurs les messieurs les sénateurs sur
ce deuxième items troisième thème c'est
permettre de
d'adopter des
outils qui permettent
l'efficacité de l'action publique et jeu
je vous réponds sur ce point en évoquant
3,3 siouxsie thème suffire le premier
c'est l'intérêt communautaire dans la
rue notre dame reçu aucune lire et
comprend l'intérêt communautaire et
quelques battues en brèche or mesdames
messieurs chers qu elle est perdante est
vous le savez ce qu vivier des
territoires l'intérêt communautaire
c'est celui qui permet de s'adapter un
territoire d'avoir donc un partage entre
ce qui est communautaire etc qui doit
rester communal et c'est différent de
territoire et territoires il ya des
territoires en fonction de leur
démographie de leur géographie de leur
expérience leur équipement humain et qui
est ok ou pas tel passage donc au niveau
communautaire ou pas il n'y a pas de
bloc et le bloc là mon sens et est
contre-productif ya pas de bloc à
transférer de façon globale donc à
l'intercours d'un exemple que je vis
dans ma clavicule au mans interco dont
transféré à l'intercommunalité toute la
partie bande de roulement de la vraie
communautaire puisque les voitures
circulent pas une commune à l'autre sans
forcément se rendre compte dans toute la
partie roulement de roulement était
transféré et
c'est l'intérêt que nos terres par
contre donc conservé de compétence
communale tout ce qui est trottoirs
éclairage public et éventuellement
rebouchage des nids-de-poule parce que
la réactivité du cantonnier locale est
plus importante et moins coûteuses et
moins coûteuse que le fait de faire
venir une équipe lourde de la ville
centre qui va donc opérer la même action
donc intercommunautaires c'est agréable
à le positionnement du curseur qui
permet l'efficacité l'action publique
avec un partage intelligent adaptée au
territoire entre ce qui doit rester
communal et ce qui doit passer à la
compétence communautaire premier ce
deuxième chose et là aussi le projet de
loi de notre en parle
la forme de mutualisation dieu sait
mais jean jacques hyest 28,2 s'est vu ce
qu est l époque il avait aussi contribué
à porter cette loi la mutualisation ça a
été la revendication de l'association
des maires de france depuis des années
né de poèmes locaux qu'on allait
rencontrer que moi je vais rencontrer où
j'avais eu l'idée de mettre en place une
direction transversale des services
entre ma ville et l'interco avec
l'accord pluraliste sur le plan
géographique sur 20 et ruraux sur le
plan politique dem et vice président de
l'intercoton mis en place une direction
générale transversale et services ans en
2000 2002 2003 et j'ai eu un contrôle la
chambre régionale des comptes qui menez
votre système c'est intelligent c'est
efficace vous avez des hommes et des
femmes qui travaillent ensemble dans le
cadre des actions transversales du
service est pour la ville et pour
l'interco mais c'est illégal et c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque en 2003 7 est illégal
il a fallu la loi du 13 juin 13 août
pardon 13 août 2004 pour que la première
mutualisation soit introduite ça a été
les services partagés les services
communs à vous suit et d'avoir donc un
partage des agents entre communes et
interco premières formes de
mutualisation époque sa boîte est
suffisant puisque la commission
européenne a déféré cette décision
devant la cour de justice européenne
et il a fallu attendre la loi du 16 août
du 16 décembre le ciment du 7 décembre
2010 pour que la mutualisation soit
sécuriser juridiquement bien organisé et
que d'ailleurs commission retire sont
déférés devant la cause du site urbaine
et puis la loi donc madame apam du 27
janvier le médiateur a confirmé cette
démarche de mutualisation aujourd'hui
tout le monde directement la musette
mutualisation c'est un bon outil donc un
outil tant mieux ils devront donc
oeuvrer pour cela mais par contre est
monsieur v center il faut que la
mutualisation soit libre j'entends
qu'elle puisse être aussi bien
ascendante que descendante tout dépend
là encore des territoires quand vous
avez plusieurs petites communes
plusieurs villes moyennes
qui sont regroupés en asie reconnaître
descendants talent de l'interco vers les
communes par contre quand une une ville
centre avec une interco qui ne regroupe
que la ville centre et des petites
communes tout petit et bien la
mutualisation peut-être où doit être à
son amante partant du noyau dur de
l'équipement humains techniques de telle
ou telle commune pour aboutir une
utilisation au profit de l'interco donc
n'ayant pas une approche
générale personnalisant de mutualisation
ne doit être que descendant l'intercours
commune et peut être à 100 noms aussi
des communes vers interco puis un jeu
beau jour tout ce tome se termine par le
transfert la compétence interco elles
sont là le la boucle est bouclée et donc
la mutualisation est ainsi abouti
s'allume une vieille mutualisation est
un élément essentiel messieurs les
sénateurs de pérennité des communes de
prague ruzyne nous sommes très attachés
et d'efficacité de l'action publique
nous savons en ces temps où les
dotations d'état s'en sont rares baisses
pour des raisons de contraintes que nous
connaissons tous nous sommes condamnés
tous avoir une démarche d'efficacité
de l'action publique et donc de
mutualisation puis derniers éléments sur
les outils d'efficacité vraiment ac
accueille une nouvelle je vais parler
avec monsieur le président bat avec les
deux rapporteurs ici présents c'est un
outil qui paraît intéressant puisque
c'est la forme la plus aboutie de
mutualisation c'est à la fois la
sécurité la solidarité donc et la
transparence démocratique au sein d'une
commune avec la proximité conservés
grâce aux ou aux élus proximité au maire
délégué mais aussi donc une efficacité
dansant mais une économie de temps et
d'argent voilà dernier point monsieur le
président que je tenais évoquée c'est la
question de l'évaluation financière je
le fais avec des chiffres et je vais me
sortir
la mesure où l'oiseau non nous savons
tout sur une enveloppe normée et que la
loi du 27 janvier 2014 de modernisation
d'action publique territoriale et
d'affirmation des métropoles a coûté en
ce qui concerne les métropoles environ
147 millions d'euros et l'abaissement du
seuil des cas noté d'oublier que des
urbaines 40,1 millions 765 bref c'est un
total de 187 millions de 115000 805
euros prix sur normes et donc ça peut se
concevoir
je plaide coupable
en tout cas je plaide responsables les
communes nouvelles vont aussi prendre
sur une seule enveloppe normée donc ya
pas de problème à ce sujet là toute
action publique par hypothèse 1 coûte
quand elle est effectivement porteuse de
bénéfices futurs par contre faut le
savoir donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle étude d'impact est à mon sens
nécessaire avec cette nouvelle loi
nouvelle organisation territoriale la
métropole des nouvelles agressions
territoire la république je termine sur
un sujet mais je ne vous dirai rien rap
c'est sur le seuil de 20 mille aussi et
n'ayez sortons d'une approche générale
un personnel de la république il ya des
territoires ruraux ou 20000 habitants
c'est extrêmement difficile à atteindre
ou alors avec des distances
qui vont coûter cher en terme de gestion
par contre en zone urbaine rémy nice et
peut donc laissons là aussi les
territoires se déterminer les sons les
élus hommes et femmes responsables
souvent au delà des étiquettes
politiques donc décidé avec leur
intelligence collective
où est le positionnement du bon du bon
curseur plutôt que d'avoir un chiffre
tournant arithmétique donc qui
s'appliquerait à tous qui s'imposerait à
tous moi je préfère une approche donc
territoriale n'approche adaptée au
territoire plutôt que positionnement
purement arithmétique d'un curseur sur
l'ensemble du territoire national je
crois que sur ce jeu là des évolutions
positives sont à attendre et à y compris
avec l'accord du gouvernement la mesure
président à grands traits ce que je
tenais à dire rien n'ayant j'espère
respecter le quart d'heure que me vient
parti et tu aurais pu être naturellement
dépasser si vous aviez souhaité mais
vous pourrez vous détendre plus
longuement sur ses différents aspects en
réponse aux questions qui vont vous être
posée monsieur puisségur vous souhaitiez
sans doute
ajouter votre propre propos merci
mesdames les sénateurs bonjour
j'évoquerai suite au président pélissard
sur tous les problèmes de la ruralité
puisque je suis mère moi même d'une
commune de 930 habitants près des
pyrénées et c'est un sujet que je pense
je connais particulièrement bien
notamment sur le plan financier donc par
rapport à l'évolution actuelle les
communes rurales ne comprennent pas je
ne sais pas si les communes urbaines
comprennent mieux mais les communes
rurales d'une manière générale les élus
donnent comme nuri vers israël ne voit
pas très bien le chaînage entre
l'évolution législative actuelle pour
débuter sur le plan des ressources
financières je vous disais que je vous
dirais que la ruralité se fait du souci
par rapport aux sur ce financière mais
d'une manière générale les communes
rurales sont habitués à la disette
tellement leurs bases fiscales sont
faibles et qu'elles n'ont pas de ces
feux dont le problème est relativement
clair donc je vous disais que par
rapport au paiement des régions par
rapport à la réflexion des élus c'est un
problème qui touche plus les élus de
terrain et je peux pas dire qu'ils aient
une inflexion
pour secteur ou pour une autre notamment
pour nous concerne en midi-pyrénées ou
languedoc roussillon par contre par
rapport à l'évolution des conseils
généraux c'est un beau sujet parce que
les conseils généraux sur les premiers
partenaires institutionnels des communes
rurales et plus particulièrement dans
notre département sur le plan des aides
à l'investissement ca légèrement diminué
mais les aides à l'investissement était
systématiquement de l'ordre de 50 à 70%
pour tous jugés et c'était rare les
sujets sur lesquels le conseil général
de haute garonne n'intervenez pas avec
un petit bémol il n'y avait aucune
écoute il n'y avait absolument aucune
écoute de la mef puisque c'était
purement et simplement et je peux le
dire une attitude politique qui
consistait arroser les cantons pour
avoir des conseillers généraux à sa
botte et il n'y a pas du tout eu d'un
discernement dans les aides
structurantes
n'exagère âge pourrait dire que le même
pourcentage de subvention était attribué
un maire qui faisait une salle des fêtes
avec le marbre tour que celui qui le
faisait en bois c'était une âme général
d'ag général une exagération
politique mais la haute garonne ce
particulier à sa particularité c'est une
métropole d'un million d'habitants et le
reste du monde rural qui fait 200 milles
et j'ai l'habitude de dire que
concernant ces de 5000 habitants si nous
n'avions pas toulouse sur le plan de la
géographie de la valeur agronomique des
sols de l'habitat nous ressemblons
métrage marne aux départements voisins
que sont la haute garonne l'ariège le
gers ou autres et ces départements la
vivent mal le l'espèce de facilités
financières comme les communes du
département de la haute garonne surtout
limitrophes où je pense que c'est
important par rapport à aux conseils
généraux parce que c'est un réflexe
purement égoïste dans le département de
la haute garonne que de vouloir les
conserver et
cette attitude est bien entendu comprise
comme prise par les élus si je reviens
sur la faiblesse agronomique des sols et
sur le problème de l'appareil productif
dans les zones rurales vous connaissez
parfaitement mais que j'ai l'habitude
d'écrire de la manière suivante ma
commune qui fait 1400 hectares avaient
après-guerre 60 petites exploitations
ces exploitations bien entendu faire ici
vivent 4 u th quatre personnes puisque
le plus souvent ces deux générations qui
travaillait
si on multiplie 60 par quatre on va
trouver 240 emplois productifs alors
vous me citez pas des emplois productifs
bien terrible selon vous parlez quand
même figurez-vous que après guerre et je
connais bien après guerre et bien un
agriculteur vivait mieux que n'ouvriers
l'ouvrier se déplacer en vélo ou en
mobylette pour aller à l'usiné et
l'agriculteur même avec sa petite
exploitation vivrière de 12 ou ou 14
étapes vivait mal l'évolution des prix
agricoles a été telle que même fait je
m'arrête sur ce point 240 emplois
productifs aujourd'hui à huit
exploitations avaient cinq emplois
productifs et demain il y en aura une et
dans certaines communes aucune le solde
net on va dire aux moyens c'est 200
emplois productifs pour les communes
rurales
et ça n'a été remplacé par rien
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'emplois de
services et d'un poids de commerce et
autres mais l'emploi productif n'est pas
là et je pense que si on devait diriger
une ressource financière supplémentaire
vers les communes rurales ce devrait
être pour des 1/2 structurantes à
l'appareil productif plutôt que d'aller
subventionné tel ou tel équipement qui
serait pourtant nécessaire
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus parce qu'à
mon avis on l'entend pas suffisamment la
ruralité a perdu une activité à l'école
particulièrement importantes sur
l'emploi productif et d'une manière
générale c'est improductif a été
remplacé par rien et surtout pas pour
des emplois productifs il ya des pistes
que vous connaissez tous eu la forêt la
valorisation direct mais sur le plan
agricole et des zones d'élevage cette
valorisation direct n'est pas arrivée là
la valorisation ne se fait pas sur les
territoires se fait partout ailleurs et
d'une manière générale sur la viande la
valorisation jeunesse hijab libyenne
concrétiser j'insiste sur sur cette
cette population vieillissante
actuellement de la ruralité sur une
exportation intellectuelle aussi ai-je
assiste au phénomène suivant pour le
vivre puisque je suis président d'un
sivom de 200 habitants est de 20
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
ce qu'il y a des gens qui ont des jeunes
qui ont un potentiel actuel intéressant
mais qui veulent rester au pays et qui
viennent chez nous pour conduire les
engins de chantier pour être chauffeur
routier le vrai problème qui est posé
c'est que ces gens là un postulat de
telle place prennent la place des gens
pour lesquels le travail est destiné et
on a une population très importante de
personnes qui sont laissés pour compte
pour mot que je ne vais pas appeler mais
par faiblesse intellectuelle pour
laquelle des emplois de base seraient
désignés qui sont pris par par des gens
qui veulent rester au pays et prend des
impôts supérieurs dont les demandes de
ses innombrables ces jarres effectués
ainsi à eux ils partent ensuite bien
entendu rarement sont embauchés puisque
les collectivités ne peuvent pas ils
vont passer un petit âne de chômage puis
revient à ses yeux etc et leur carrière
professionnelle se déroule
malheureusement ainsi sur les intercoms
je vous dirais qu'en zone rurale il ya
une vraie difficulté des élus locaux des
communes rurales appréhender
l'intercommunalité le maire les délégués
le ou les délégués dans les communes
vivent l'intercommunalité comme
élargissant l'éventail de leurs
compétences de la réflexion ils ont
beaucoup de mal à transmettre le message
du fonctionnement interco aux conseils
municipaux qui ne vivent pas et qu'ils
en vivent pas et c'est très difficile à
faire passer ce message là souvent les
intercommunalités je prends quelques
mauvais exemple parce que je tenais à
vous les donnez nous sommes que dd
compression des budgets des villes
centres et les communes périphériques
subissent vous allez me dire c'est le
jeu des élus locaux il n'empêche que
bien souvent une dame aux dénominations
existe et qu'elle est bien souvent
qu'elle est bien souvent politique
la disparité des intercoms je vous en
parlerai aussi puisque la réponse
systématique et d'avenir ne peut pas
être l'intercommunalité et du moins que
ça
si vous réunissez
25 communes pauvres vous ferez une
intercommunalité pauvres qui ne visera
pas davantage que les 21 communes qui
travaillaient séparément ou très peu non
c'est souvent les intercommunalités se
sont lancés dans des dépenses un petit
peu exceptionnel comme étant des
collectivités jeunes qui voulaient bien
entendu avancée s'est calmée depuis la
fiscalité directe il semblait qu'il y
avait une corne d'abondance qui venait
de l'état il y en avait pas de relation
directe avec la avec les populations la
fiscalité directe et convenus qu'en même
réveillé un certain nombre d'élus et les
ramener à la raison par contre chez nous
du moins et pour en parler à d'autres
amis c'est vrai sur tout le territoire
national
si les intercommunalités sont parfois
mal vécue et parfois n'amène pas ce que
l'on pourrait être espérée
les élus sont revenus dans les pays où
les scot c'est une autre échelle avec
une économie quand on parle économie
dans un scot c'est beaucoup plus
favorable qu'en tant par le tourisme au
niveau d'un pays si beaucoup plus
favorable plutôt que dc mais chacun est
de faire la promotion de
son histoire les pays également sont
également choyés pour linstruction futur
des permis de construire c'est un
phénomène que l'on ne peut pas imaginer
sur les c'est une europe et à ce qu'on
ne peut pas imaginer sur les intercoms
seul ça correspond parfois admis ou
trois quarts d'emploi de la djt actuelle
et les élus voient très bien et les
résonne très bien
cette instruction des permis de
construire au niveau des pays et sont
prêts à la rejeter au niveau des
intercoms c'est un phénomène que
jean-marc ensuite je tenais à vous dire
que les élus est une véritable volonté
pour ceux que je connais une sorte de
rejet du pouvoir politique dominant vous
allez me dire que c'est une
caractéristique de mon département mais
je pense que c'est général
les conseillers municipaux ont changé
les conseils municipaux chargés
ce ne serait plus les conseils
municipaux le passé municipal où le
maire d'illies avec ou 30 ans qui allait
faire son budget le percepteur qui lui
demandait avec un crayon comment m les
chiffres supplémentaires par rapport à
l'année n ou et damoiseaux aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de jeunes dans les fossés
municipaux sont tout à fait conscients
des difficultés financières et qui
sommes pas des rêveurs mais qu'ils
veulent qu'ils veulent s'investir et ça
c'est un véritable plaidoyer sur la
commune par rapport à la différence avec
darko je vous assure que c'est moi je
suis très heureux de voir dans ma
commune autant de conseillers jeunes
s'investir et s'investir bénévolement
milan duo au service de la commune notez
que les conseils municipaux ont
énormément changé ça sur l'évolution de
la ressource financière des communes il
faut que je vous parle un peu de notre
chère métropole puisque si le conseil
général qui aujourd'hui aides à
l'investissement
ce serait quand même bien que la
métropole puisque les consignes du guide
consacré consacrer une part de ses
ressources financières rurales alors ils
sont tout à fait d'accord sur le
principe étant pierre cohen il ya
quelques temps que jean luc moudenc
aujourd'hui il considérait le rural et
les imagine pouvoir l'aider mais ici on
leur demande pas ils ont suffisamment de
soucis ils ne le feront pas alors à
quelle échelle ici à paris je peux le
dire à quelle échelle travailler avec la
métropole
tentons de travailler à l'échelle
régionale avec un bout d'échapper
départements qui touchent la métropole
autant que la haute garonne vous
attendent travailler uniquement dans le
département c'est vrai sujet - façon
égoïste je vous dirais le conseil
général de la haute-garonne
faisait de la péréquation la ressource
financière toulousaine ce serait bien
que la métropole continue mais en
réalité avec bon sens c'est au niveau
régional que ça devrait se voir et pour
être habitude à l'habitude par les
francs j'en ai parlé à mon ami jean
michel baylet qui a commandé chacun sait
une centrale nucléaire et il m'a dit
d'une façon très claire surtout moins
bête pas avec ça chaque conseil général
vegal chaque département veut garder
quand il a de la ressource ces faveurs
j'aime bien préciser un certain nombre
de points le plus ceux qui cherchent
principalement les communes déjà figuré
par là sur la ressource financière c'est
le problème de la voirie
la voirie telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
sup aux environs de 10 à 15000 euros
d'investissement tous les dix ans une
couche de surface tous les dix ans le
conseil généra et d en hauteur de 70%
les communes de moins de 400 habitants
50 % les autres les maires ne savent pas
comment il faut faire et il va très
certainement falloir pour remettre au
revêtement d'anciens hommes un certaine
nombre de chemins ruraux que nous avons
goudronnées et que ne voudront plus que
nous ne pourrons plus entretenir sur les
communes nouvelles j'ai un mauvais
exemple à vous donner la seule commune
nouvelle et je plaide pour une commune
nouvelle moi je pensais que c'était
uniquement un phénomène périurbaines et
appliquées ou périurbaines les communes
nouvelles je vois pas très bien je vois
pas du tout avec l'attachement que les
élus auront à leur commune comment on
peut plaider comme une nouvelle dans le
rural ça viendra peut-être avec le temps
le mauvais exemple que j'essayais
intercours rural relativement propre qui
a beaucoup investi à tort et qui est
absolument exact depuis l'environnement
dont le président plaide la commune
nouvelle pour aller chercher un petit
peu plus de ressources financières pour
se sortir un petit peu de la panade sur
celle des 1000 habitants c'est une
véritable inquiétude
chez les élus ruraux qui sont dans les
airs que de 5 ou 6000 je pense que c'est
un problème de temps il faut qu'ils
raisonnent eux mêmes il faut les laisser
résonner même il faut que ça s'impose à
eux comme étant une solution financière
pratiquement la seule mais absolument
pas leur mettre des échéances telles
qu'elles ont été mises aux biens des
objectifs chaque territoire est
différent de notre ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de travailler ensemble je les
intercours ont traité un pas que vous
pouvez pas imaginer dans le rural de
travailler de façon mutuelle dans les
intercommunalités et communes ce
phénomène de seuils de 20 mille
habitants ça viendra mais il faut
absolument laisser du temps au temps ils
essaient les élus raisonnée eux mêmes la
preuve il y a plusieurs secteurs dans le
département de la haute garonne
vous savez forcé se sont mis à discuter
ensemble à faire des études économiques
et autres mais absolument pas sur un
message d'état est encore au moins un
préfectorale je suis je vous ai donné
quelques exemples concrets pour
illustrer mon raisonnement merci
beaucoup monsieur puisségur
monsieur jean jacques hyest à porter
ainsi que monsieur van beirendonck
également rapporteur vont intervenir
maintenant et vous posez peut-être
quelques questions
d'hier à entendre présent pélissard et
puis aussi
mal émanation du monde rural avec
présent puisque jean louis puissegur
parce qu'il ya encore des il ya même des
sénateurs qui sont non même qu'à vous
voyez c'est pas même en ile-de-france
loyers a pu exister
néanmoins alors il ya un certain nombre
de choses que vous avez dit
gg pas très bien compris je le dois le
dire si vous tenez au maintien du
département
attendez je vais continuer mes questions
1 parce que intercommunalités ou
département en même temps dit il faut
pas que les intercommunalités soit trop
importante parce qu'à ce moment là il y
aura plus de qui on a eu du mal à faire
la carte
spontanée pas tout à fait parce qu'on
avait quand même fortement incité les
élus à se regrouper en intercommunalité
là où il y en avait pas c'est vrai que
là le rôle de la commission
départementale composée d'élus
essentiellement de mère avait eu un rôle
quand même déterminant et ça s'est passé
sauf exception plutôt bien les préfets
temps prudents ayant laissé les élus
mais donc je crois que je suis d'accord
il faut pas tout bouleverser la carte
vient de se terminer il faut sans doute
faire évoluer certaines
intercommunalités qui ne sont pas
cohérentes toujours parce que la carte
est pas cohérente mais pas aller trop
vite je pense que c'est le sentiment à
peut qu'exprimer monsieur puisségur
alors ensuite
veuillez m'excuser sur les schémas je
comprends que vous on est beaucoup de
réticence à ce qui est des schémas
prescriptif
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que si on
confie explicitement dans la loi d'une
responsabilité à une collectivité je
parle notamment tout ce qui les
orientations en matière de aides aux
entreprises et cetera il faut bien quand
même que ça soit la collectivité
après la toute la concertation
nécessaire qui décide est-ce qu
autrement si on fait des schémas pour ce
faire je suis d'accord sur une petite
enfance c'est quand même pas très
cohérente demandé au département de
faire un film à de la petite enfance
alors qui met quatre sous aix et
d'autres qui finance un c'est comme
l'état d'ailleurs qui dit moi je vais
vous faire des crèches vous allez voir
en fait 90 % céder la caf et les
communes
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
fortement augmenté le personnel communal
parce qu'il y avait il ya eu des besoins
considérables et oui parce que quand on
dit pour qu'on ait augmenté personnel
communal c'est pour ça en partie en
partie bon donc
il ya un problème
et puis
alors sur les sur tout ce qui est
surtout ce qui est l'ingénierie
moi je crois qu'il faut être pragmatique
il ya des départements qui ont des
services qui se sont mis à disposition
des communes ça peut marcher
tant d'ailleurs pour les services
techniques pour les saules et des
départements ils ont aussi d'aider les
anciennes subdivision ils ont créé tout
ça
ça peut être le cas aussi en matière
d'urbanisme mais je crois que le pire
c'est très nouveau service si on n'est
pas capables de mutualiser notion web
qu'elle vous êtes attachés et encourager
cette mutualisation
on n'aboutira à rien
je pense que l'instruction des permis de
construire 2 doit demeurer une
compétence communale n'est pas question
ça sera pas le maire mais pour
l'instruction on avait laissé non mais
on avait les services oui même certains
diraient pourquoi veux laisser ça
pourquoi ne pas donner ça vaut président
de l'intercommunalité en a qui disent ça
si si si si si si les voir ce que
l'intercommunalité c'est la merveille et
paraît alors c'est tout formidable bond
un ca doivent remplacer les bons mais
par contre pour l'instruction il faut
bien avoir des techniciens alors quand
vous avez la chance d'avoir une ville
avec des services structurés on peut
partager comme vous l'avait expérimenté
monsieur le président et ça c'est le bon
exemple mais je crois qu'il faut pas
dire
tous les est-ce qu'il faut que dans
notre pays tout fonctionne comme avec
les dde les dde et autre chose non je
crois qu'il faut laisser beaucoup de
souplesse et il ya des choses qui vaut
mieux pas mettre dans la loi mais il ya
des départements qui est ici on kir
offert leurs services aux matière de
voirie par exemple aux collègues aux
communautés ou aux communes bon si ça
marche bien cissé mutualiser vos pelles
coût du service pour pourquoi pas il ya
des techniciens qui ont peut-être un
petit peu de un petit peu de encore de
disponibilité de temps comme quand même
aussi l'objectif est quand même de faire
des économies donc c'est quand même la
mutualisation et vous l'avez dit
inquiets quand même
mais qu'est-ce que pas
dans un seul sens quoi fins et ça je
crois est-ce qu'il faut louer ce qu'il
faut légiférer là dessus ou est-ce qu'il
faut encourager la mutualisation et
faire en sorte que plus est mutualisé
plus on aide un petit peu pour favoriser
cette mutualisation c'est notre question
et qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'intercommunalité cetera qui ont été
créé au départ pour des raisons
financières ce que j'appelais l'ailé les
communautés de communes vide en à
corriger les choses au fil des années
mais c'est un petit peu ça quand même
c'était pour avoir les carottes fiscales
d'ailleurs ça a été pratiquée depuis
très longtemps déjà en 72 les districts
avaient la carotte fiscale
et des districts de la loi marcellin
déjà et ça a continué à chaque fois que
vous voulez un certain temps ça diminue
donc voilà quelques questions je me pose
à l écoute de votre
de votre de vote de vos propos c'était
très intéressant et pleins d'expérience
alors monsieur le président
habituellement
nos rapporteur puis les collègues
présents pose des questions et les
personnalités invitées
répondent ensuite mais il ya une
question dont la réponse ne peut
vraiment pas tendre qui nous a mis à
tous un très grand stress c'est la
question de des départements
jéhovah je crois qu'il faut que vous
répondiez maintenant
et puis après je rendrai la parole au
club des rapporteurs
rené vandierendonck et puis les
collègues qui le souhaitent
pourront se manifester et peuvent déjà
le faire on note leino et puis après je
donne la parole aux uns et aux autres
alors s'il vous plaît dites nous
je vous dis monsieur présente et je vous
les vivez vous lier à vous tous chers
creil comme je le dis avec la même
sincérité au présent public m'avait
interrogé à ce sujet et comme il va
interroger d'autres associations d'élus
locaux sachant que la position que je
vais exprimer est une position
personnelle et d'après été passés au
crible du jugement du bureau de m f on
n'a pas eu à déterminer est terminée sur
les départements ne s'occupe que des
communes et intercos du bloc local la
question et précise quid des
départements alors j'ai dit au président
public jeudi à vous même chose je
considère que si on avait conservé des
régions à taille humaine les anciennes
régions de taille relativement modeste
on pouvait à son la supprimer les
départements et répartir entre l'état
les régions et interco des compétences
et toutes les croyances proximité
pouvait être affectés aux aux
interprétations
assumer des critiques de guichet de type
rsa qui l'initient lire lui-même et
comme d'ailleurs la gestion des services
incendie et de secours et puis les
régions avaient une pleine compétence
sur les bleus pointent économique et sur
les questions d'infrastructures
bref ceci étant quand c'était dans les 4
de gain de région sa taille limitée à
très humaine comme on ne les connaissons
aujourd'hui dès lors qu'on passe à des
grandes régions que dans notre jargon
associations doivent prendre et plomb
les régions xxl qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
13 ou 15 ha sont là il faut à mon sens
conserver des espaces de proximité et
construit un niveau de proximité et ce
qui est celui qui est partout par contre
avec une nuance que j'apporte tout de
suite on ne peut pas à ce moment-là
avoir des départements qui est d'une
clause de compétence générale la clause
de compétence générale un qui a été
ressuscité si je puis dire par le
discours du programme public 1 sorbonne
le 6 octobre 2012 mon sens et elle était
une erreur aujourd'hui il faut bien que
chacun sache qu'il fait que les
départements et les régions et des
clauses de compétences spéciales donc
résume grande région s'implique des
départements des départements comme les
régions avec eux mais avec des
compétences spéciales merci monsieur le
président compte tenu de votre réponse
l'audition peut se poursuivre monsieur
van dieren donc
la question complémentaire
être pôle représente 80% du de la
démographie d'un département etc qu'est
ce qui se passe et ça voudrait poser la
question pour toulouse mais ça se pose
ailleurs avec l'exemple
type euskadi un président
juste un petit mot
j'aborderai le problème de la politique
si on pose la question aux maires de mon
département de savoir s'ils veulent
garder le département niveau dire oui
mais par intérêt financier évident mais
par raisonnement de démocratie locale
surtout pas et c'est là quand même un
problème cette suppression ne gênerait
pas mais je je reviens quand même la
rgpp un petit peu
nous avions en matière d'ingénierie et
autres un état performant neutre et
compétent
et je préférerais et de très loin m que
ce soit une organisation intercommunale
qui le remplace plutôt qu'un pouvoir
politique ce pouvoir politique il est
aujourd'hui pouvoir politique politicien
je veux aller un peu plus loin il est
rejeté à la tête des intercommunalités
les communes peuvent le pouvoir gérer
eux mêmes sans avoir un pouvoir
politique qui s'adresse qui les géants
comme une chape de plomb
c'est dans plusieurs départements par
contre moi j'aurais très bien vu un
schéma communes pays où scott région
tels quels que soient les présidents et
surtout pas trop grande parce que à les
promouvoir l'intercommunalité avec un
scot des pays qui ont un avenir et qui
ont une forme de mutualisation
je vous dirais ok pour supprimer le
département on supprime aussi les
intercours on travaille un pays et on
regarde surtout les communes comme
échelons de base
ainsi monsieur puisségur alors monsieur
val d'irène donc
président pélissard
rappeler mais vous le savez bien
position
du sénat illustré par plusieurs de nos
membres je pense à monsieur mézard et
d'autres
s'étaient pas de condamner
la nécessité
d'un lieu où l'état
et les mots ont un sens les trois
associations de collectivités
territoriales généralistes
puissent se concerter
ensemble on y ajouter une représentation
bien sûr du sénat qui représente les
collectivités territoriales
personnellement je voyais que des
avantages à ce que les députés soient
aussi
donc ce qui a jeté le trouble c'est
qu'effectivement intervenant dans le
débat en même temps sur le cumul ce ça
exactement le même problème qu'avec les
départements ici c'est devenu un
problème existentiel
que vous l'êtes offert du sénat a que
vous les tons faire des départements et
on est passé à côté de l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que celui où on en a
besoin et donc pas plus tard que c'est
sous votre contrôle président et co
rapporteur on disait à madame le mans
juan commission des lois plus tard
qu'hier
simple décret
un simple décret suffi pour mettre en
place cette instance qui est de vous à
moi ça devrait bien possible et je
m'arrête un moment là dessus parce que
je voudrais vous dire moi que vraiment
la découverte que je fais
parce qu'il ya au dessus du millefeuille
il ya la représentation du monde
communal et je voudrais vous dire qu'on
atteint un seuil excessivement dangereux
quand on voit la manière dont est en
train de se fragmenter se segmenter 1
la représentation du monde
intercommunale et donc moi j'appelle de
mes voeux à skis un cadre généraliste et
jeudi à des gens que je pour lesquels
chez un infini respect je suis allé à
leur congrès bas au congrès de la dcn
moi je le dis mais qu'est ce que vous
attendez
pour puisque vous vous nous dites plein
communal blocs mieux pour faire une
représentation
intégré de ce bloc communal et non pas
fragmenté dont je vais vous le dire
parce que c'est véritablement un des
problèmes qu'on rencontre à travers
l'examen de ces textes successifs alors
pour le reste la télé communautaire on
peut dire tout et son contraire on peut
dire comme vous attention faut garantir
et moi je suis cette école là on s'est
battus 6 pour sa com et y est ce bien
avant nous on peut dire c'est la
garantie de la subsidiarité
d'accord a contrario peut-être que vous
pouvez accepter votre les cas j'aimerais
avoir votre avis vous acceptez de dire
que la terre et communautaires ou si ça
peut être
ce qui intéresse
l'intercommunalité
sachant que le reste on laisse aux
autres regardez bien
regardez bien comment alors que tout le
monde fait blu ray haute
la défense de l'artisanat
le petit commerce
ont fait un petit fisac ici on attend 15
heures pour voir le premier centime
mais et et moi par exemple que quand je
porte le débat dans la communauté
urbaine de lille qui a pris la
compétence de développement économique
attention on a pris la compétence
économique intérêts communautaires ou
lui je les filières les pôles de
compétitivité a french tech un
mecha vous venez à a parlé
la fermeture du petit caux bien c'est
déjà moins de monde au portillon 1 et
quand vous poussez un peu dans les
retranchements on vous dit mais est ce
que c'est vraiment une compétence
communautaire après qu'on l'a pas pris
puisque on n'a pas dit que c'était
d'intérêt communautaire vous portez le
débat culturel dans une intercommunalité
comme la communauté urbaine de lille ils
vont vous dire ouais l'opéra leur quête
nationale
legrand événementiel
d'accord mais les acteurs les troupes
amateurs
de terrain les communes là comme pas oui
donc on aura dans le débat sur la loi
nôtre mais votre éclairage est le
bienvenu à déterminer comment et j'en
suis on concilie une subsidiarité en
faisant attention que la subsidiarité
soit pas la manière dont
l'intercommunalité se dégage de ce
qu'elle veut pas regarder
voilà
merci
sa collègue monsieur rémy pointereau qui
est le rapporteur pour avis de la
commission du développement durable
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président pélissard et
monsieur puisségur de nous avoir fait
une présentation et donnait déjà
l'heureux leurs points de vue sur 7 sur
cette réforme et à partir du moment où
le président pélissard s'est prononcé
sur les départements je partage en
grande part ce qui était dit
sûr
sur cette réforme d'abord de dire qu'il
aurait fallu une loi cadre et et quand
on regarde l'impact financier je pense
que c'était
éminemment nécessaire
moi je voulais avoir votre avis sur
plusieurs choses
puisque maintenant vous nous dites que
le département est nécessaire avec des
grandes régions
votre avis sur le fait que ce matin
écoutez la la dfl arf et il semble que
donc les transports scolaires par
exemple seraient confiées
région ainsi que les collèges
à partir vraiment les communes ont les
écoles primaires et que le collège un
peu là une logique entre le collège et
l'école primaire une logique entre les
transports scolaires du monde primaires
et des collèges comment quel est votre
avis sur le sujet est-ce que vous pensez
que ça va être une bonne chose pour les
communes d'avoir affaire à une région
qui est un peu lointaine pour gérer nos
transports scolaires et nos collèges
deuxième chose
concernant les syndicats d'énergie là
aussi il ya une volonté de certains
départements
de reprendre scott s'est pas fait de
reprendre les syndicats d'énergie
d'électricité les anciens syndicats
d'électricité
en compétence des départements
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui syndicat
d'énergie font beaucoup de travaux pour
les communes en terme de free se pendent
réseau et c est là aussi j'aurais aimé
avoir votre point de vue sur est ce que
c'est une bonne chose
que les départements reprennent cette
compétence par rapport au bloc communal
un autre point également vous avez
évoqué le l'intérêt communautaire est là
et la mutualisation c'est vrai qu'on
nous bassine ans qui va être dit mais
mes excuses avec la mutualisation mais
on en fait depuis longtemps que monsieur
jourdain faisait de la prose sans le
savoir parce que la mutualisation déjà
d'avoir fait le pas de la communauté de
communes
c'est déjà une mutualisation quand on
sait par exemple que depuis on a fait
des déchetteries qu'on n'avait pas dans
nos secteurs dont vannes a bien
mutualiser des choses les spanc qu'on
aurait pu faire chacun dans la commune
on a on l'a fait très souvent au niveau
d'une communauté de communes ça nous a
fait embaucher du personnel et après on
nous dit que on a trop de personnel que
la cour des comptes nous dit qu'on a
dépensé beaucoup trop mais c'est aussi
parce que on appris des compétences et
qu'on nous a donné des obligations
mois ce qui nous fait peur dans la
mutualisation c'est qu'on nous dit
sur le terrain par le biais des
préfectures que les dotations à l'avenir
seront données en fonction d'un mythe du
degré de mutualisation est-ce que c'est
pas une contrainte vous avez dit mme se
présente ce devait être libre mais est
ce qu'on sera libre de l'utiliser si on
nous dit demain si vous n'avez pas fait
telle mutualisation vous donnera pas la
dotation maximum donc
ça c'est un sujet qui me qui me qui est
un peu et puis le dernier point sur le
seuil de 20 mille habitants pour les
communautés de communes
c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'on sorte de
cette logique démographique
on est toujours dans le raisonnement
quantitatif il faudrait peut-être mettre
un peu plus d'humain dans tout ça je
pense qu'à un moment donné faut plus
parler de qualitatif et d'humains et moi
je vous rejoins sur le fait que
aujourd'hui le seuil de cinq mille
habitants
est-ce que vous pensez que
si on mettait que les départements par
le biais des comités commission de
coopération intercommunale décidé par
département du seuil de l'interco
qui soit
gérable et qui soit efficace est-ce que
vous pensez que ça serait une bonne
chose que ce soit gérée par
je pars chaque département alors soit
par le courrier du conseil général soit
par le biais cette commission de
coopération intercommunale puisque les
représentent toutes les régions les deux
des mères les conseils généraux est-ce
que c'est pas dans cette structure qu'on
pourrait dire voilà dans notre
département est bien le minimum d'une
communauté de communes et de remettre de
sa mine mais de 7000 habitants hulu
peut-être de plus et je pense qu est ce
que ça serait pour vous une chose qui
pourrait se concevoir à travers cette
réforme
je vois pas d'autres si monsieur
bonhomme
excusez moi c'est juste pour rebondir ce
que généralement mon collègue pointereau
concernant la mutualisation dans quelle
mesure rien quel est votre sentiment sur
le fait suivant
par rapport
aux mesures et dispositions qui
pourraient inciter fortement
la mutualisation est donc le conditions
de conditions de la dotation par exemple
au coefficient d'intégration fiscale et
dans quelle mesure ce
éléments de mutualisation plus ou moins
marche forcée viendrait en contradiction
avec le principe de libre administration
des collectivités locales
merci cher collègue monsieur longchamp
oui merci merci au président de
l'association des maires de france
et puis monsieur puisségur de leur
intervention moi je pose un certain
nombre de questions et ça a été évoqué
lors du débat sur le redécoupage des
régions mais on va pas revenir dessus
mais on a fait à mon avis une première
erreur c'est celle de se dire bah on va
parler du découpage des territoires
et puis maintenant on va mettre des
compétences donc on va essayer de
glisser un peu de compétences quelque
part et puis de se dire bien comment on
fait pour essayer de contenter un peu
tout le monde et est ce que disait rémy
pointereau est très intéressant sur
sur l'idée qu'ils avancent beaucoup
quand même un de se dire ben au titre
des syndicats d'énergie
projet de reprise des compétences
afférentes à la distribution
d'électricité boschi d'eau potable à et
puis de redonner cela au département à
ça veut dire que d'un côté on nous a
expliqué beck le département il avait
vécu où il fallait le supprimer et puis
de l'autre côté on demand derrière on va
alors je mon imagination c'est certain
sans doute de se dire comment on fait
fonctionner ses structures puisque
n'importe comment on a plus de
financement donc c'est surtout les
financements je pense qu'ils s'en rend
intéressante qui intéresse et comme mon
ami je veux dire on a regardé sur le
découpage des territoires avant
effectivement bien de prendre les
compétences on se trouve aujourd'hui
dans une situation qui va être
joints présent pélissard sur ce sujet on
va se trouver dans une situation qui va
être ingérable comment avec des grandes
régions 1 comment on va faire et pour
nous la bourgogne franche comté comment
on va gérer un les transports scolaires
alors qu'on n'y arrive déjà pas
moi ya encore un mois avant des
sénateurs j'étais conseiller général je
peux vous dire que c'était l'un des
sujets sur lesquels on avait beaucoup
d'observations sur les transports
scolaires en transportant m 28 mille
enfants dans le département du doubs
comment on va faire quand on va
transporter des gamins combien
d'ailleurs entre la région de
franche-comté et et
et la bourgogne et puis pour les autres
régions d'ailleurs c'est pas uniquement
pour la main je crois qu'il faut à sûr
il faut vraiment enlever ce critère de
de vingt mille habitants pourquoi pas 10
9820 pourquoi pas 21 1412 il faut
enlever ce critère totalement parce que
moi je crois qu'il faut que l'on arrête
vraiment cette fois-ci de raisonner en
nombre d'habitants est-ce qu'on va
revenir au raisonnement du territoire
dans une intercommunalité avec quelle
commune on a envie de travailler comment
on a envie de trail et je crois que le
sujet où il est très important c'est
surtout
et comment les gens vivent exactement
voilà et comment les gens vivent est
exactement comment les gens vivent et et
et surtout je je je je crois aussi que
il est important de raisonner
effectivement sur sur le territoire et
je crois que à partir du moment où on
laissait on laisserait un petit peu de
liberté aux élus je crois que ce serait
leur rendre un peu de confiance aux élus
de base je crois que c'est le maître mot
c'est un petit peu de rendre la
confiance aux élus voilà et puis on
pourrait revenir aussi sur l'épée lui on
voit la difficulté
pour mettre en place un p lus dans une
commune de moins de 1000 habitants ou 15
cents habitants à moi je pourrais vous
citer les exemples où ça va durer dix
ans je vous dis pas si jamais il met en
place un p lui mon avis pas passer des
générations de mer avant qu'on ait
abouti aux documents d'urbanisme
attendu voilà merci merci chers
collègues avant de vous laisser la
parole monsieur le président je voudrais
ajouter un élément de la question sur
les intercommunales voilà pour ces
auditions de la commission des lois du
sénat